we have time for just one more story
this is what I'm
liking so you've all probably heard of
Cabbage Patch dolls right you heard
cabbage Pat we're around the same age
nice people went absolute nuts for them
when they came out in 1983 the year
after I was born it was almost cool uh
the demand was insane though these were
everywhere there's a new documentary
detailing it all called billion dooll
babies the true story of the Cabbage
Patch Kids it's in theaters November
24th we actually have the director on
the line right now so everybody say hi
to Andrew jenss come
on what's up Andrew so why this
story you know it's crazy because when
you go on YouTube even and just look up
Cabbage Patch Kids you just see these
insane riots in malls and stores and
people going absolutely insane and so I
started to wonder like why was that what
what was going on and one thing about
the cabbage Patch Kids which people may
remember is the element of imagination
uh they built a hospital for the Cabbage
Patch Kids called baby land General uh
people dressed up at in the hospital
with thousands of dolls as doctors and
nurses and there was
ambulances and so it was just this
element of like really believing that
they're not even dolls they're kids and
in fact uh people were going so crazy
that the company that was making Cabbage
Patch Kids had to stop running
commercials because the government sued
them saying that the commercials were
harassing children since they were
promoting a doll that you could no
longer get in stores so they actually
had to stop running the commercials they
announced that and that made people want
to get them even more so it just added
to the cze oh my God what is wrong with
Humanity of course we wanted it more now
that somebody said there's none
available so well that's intriguing I
did not know any of that actually um
everybody to see more about the Cabbage
fetch kids craze check out Andrew's film
billion dooll babies it's in theaters
November 24th thank you so much Andrew
I'm liking your post
now all right y'all well we've hit that
point uh when we usually give our guests
$1,000 uh courtesy of our season long
partner pilot pin makers of G2 the go-to
pin of the Kelly Clarkson show but today
uh that that's going to go to one lucky
person in this audience so anybody wants
some
money keep your eye on this monitor
someone's face is going to pop
[Music]
up first about your hair looks
fantastic like a walking party what's
your name Lisa Lisa how are you going to
spend the
grand I don't
know well Lisa have a little fun with it
yeah have a little fun with it I have
four kids I'm sure I can figure it out
okay I have kids too spending a little
on them spend a little on yourself do
this for
me a mama of four God bless let's give
you a round well thank you Lisa thank
you to all our guests this hour Tom
Rachel Josh andz R Hunter schaer Nina
Jacobson and Francis all the great
[Music]
[Applause]
not thank you guys y have a great night
I'm going
home